the swedish company epicenter went viral
on friday when it publicized a new
technology that would implant a
microchip under your skin
to prove that you've taken the fouchy
algae
there are many lessons to take away from
this creepy turn of events first
ideas that began as wild crazy
conspiracy theories are morphing into
reality before our very eyes as we enter
into the third year of 15 days to slow
the spread
second
alex jones
is
a more reliable source of information
than about 97 of establishment news
outlets i know it's weird a lot of
people didn't expect it but just
when the frogs are gay or trans actually
and the microchips are in your skin
that's the way it is third
our political situation could get a lot
lot worse i'm michael knowles is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from kristen drumgool
who says regarding joy reid and oh enjoy
reid uh getting angry at elon musk for
calling elizabeth warren a karen uh joy
reid said no that's our word
she says it reminds me of when homer
simpson scolds a gay man for calling
himself queer by telling him that's our
word for making fun of you that's true
you can't say that elon musk you're a
white man but karen is a word that only
black people are allowed to use to make
fun of white women except joy which you
forgot what you didn't count on is that
elon musk is an african american
got you there
darling
it's confusing it's hard to wrap your
mind around it might keep you up at
night if you want to go to sleep very
quickly at night i'd recommend you check
out my pillow this christmas season my
pillow wants to give back to our
listeners you can get great discounts on
all my pillow products if you go to
mypillow.com right now and click on the
radio listener specials get deep
discounts on my pillow mattress toppers
towels and so much more for example my
pillow is offering a buy one get one
free offer on giza sheets these are top
quality sheets that you are going to
love all my pillow products come with a
60 day money back guarantee and a 10
year warranty go to mypillow.com click
on the radio listener specials for the
buy one get one free offer on the giza
sheets and use promo code daily wire at
checkout or call 800-651-1148
you'll get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the pillow
slippers the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets that is
mypillow.com enter daily wire
i love my pillow you know i love that
they're a good conservative american
patriotic company
i told you i would shop from them even
if they were run by the taliban that's
how good that's how good the products
are you can also call
1-800-651-1148 tell them daily wire sent
you that's
1-800-651-1148 the deals will not last
forever so call now
so we're now coming up on what 20
it's been 21 months or so of 15 days to
slow the spread
so we're
a little under three months away from
entering
the third
year
of the biomedical security state
and a lot of
reasonable people are looking in that
and saying this has gone too far we've
gotten way too restrictive we've upended
our society without any real effect
because the cases are still going up
all of the breakthroughs among the
vaccinated people you know all those
many many many breakthrough cases now
where i would say mo
most of my friends that have gotten it
recently have gotten the the rona have
been vaccinated so they're all
breakthroughs everyone knows people with
breakthroughs i don't know how long we
have to keep calling them breakthrough
cases
but but the takeaway of our ruling class
is not that we've gotten too restrictive
and we need to roll this back
it's that we haven't gotten restrictive
enough
if the counts keep going up and the test
positivity keeps going up we may need to
be more restrictive but for right now
people who are vaccinated and boosted
should feel reasonably comfortable the
risk is never zero that's for sure
what's the number one what's the number
you reassess that you you just suggested
i think perhaps for the first time that
you would be forced to reassess if the
numbers go up at what level meaning you
know if if you hear that it's the
positivity rate is 25 in a particular or
30 percent does that change
you know i'm not going to give you a
number
look i'm not going to give you a number
because then i could be held accountable
so i'm just going to tell you that if
you don't do exactly what i say i'm
going to lock you down moe you dirty
rotten sheep you peasant you disgusting
mongrel
yeah breathing you have germs on me
dr fauci
this
man knows politics i don't know if he
knows science all that well
it's not just a cheap knock on fauchi
because he's in the hot seat right now
there have been a lot of questions as to
his scientific competency over the years
during his many decade-long tenure at
nih
there were protests of the guy in the
80s he made a lot of really questionable
decisions
in terms of public policy in terms of
experimentation in during the aids
epidemic then obviously he made really
questionable decisions in terms of
funding gain of function research
including in china including in wuhan
where the virus started and then he's
made a lot of questionable decisions
during covet itself
so i really don't know if he knows very
much about scientists you know there was
a critic of fouchies in the 80s who
pointed out that the best scientists go
into laboratories they don't become
government administrators and so i don't
think the guy is uh you know the
greatest genius we've ever had in this
country but the one thing he really
knows about is politics and he's held
onto power really really well and even
now when he's saying we're going to have
to lock down a little bit more we might
have to well okay can you give me any
measures
that we can test this against no i can't
i'm afraid i can't
because then
then i could be held accountable what
does that mean what does it mean to be
more restricted well one thing he's
saying
regardless of the cases going up and
down or up and down
is that
we very likely will never again fly on
an airplane without that disgusting
stupid cloth in front of our face
i also wanted to ask you about what the
airline executive said this week about
masks on airplanes they uh several of
the of the top you know the ceos of the
top airlines said that on an airplane
you are actually
safer uh than you are in an icu the
protection with the filters filtration
system they have they were suggesting
that there really
isn't much of a need for a mask on an
airplane are we going to get to the
point where we won't have to wear masks
on airplanes
i don't think so i think when you're
dealing with a closed space even though
the filtration is good
that you want to go that extra step when
you have people you know you get a
flight from washington to san francisco
it's well over a five-hour flight
even though you have a good filtration
system i still believe that masks are a
prudent thing to do and we should be
doing it hey
are we ever again
going to be able to travel the way that
we traveled from the beginning of this
medium of travel until two years ago no
i don't want you to do that so no
little
say fauci
you know the louis xiv would say let's
i am the state well fauci is the state
fauci is the state and he rules by wim
and caprice and this is a reminder
of something that some of us called in
the earliest days of the epidemic hate
to say i told you so and a lot of even
self-styled conservatives and the
squishes and the liberals and obviously
the left did not get this this was never
temporary this was never going to be
temporary it was never going to be 15
days it was never going to be just wear
the mask for a little bit and we can
return to normal it was never going to
be just get one shot or even just get
two shots and then we can return it was
never going to be that it was always a
permanent power grab these people these
power mad people like dr fauci never
give up power that they have taken
so it was never going away
and we're entering into year three and
if we don't do anything politically to
change this
then we're going to enter into year four
and five and six and seven
the only way this ends is to fire dr
fauci prosecute him then banish him to
saint helena i'm not even really being
that hyperbolic
if you told me right now there were some
constitutional means to balance this
power mad twerp to saint helena i would
gladly do it if we could establish a
colony on the moon and send dr fauci
there on a one-way ticket to the moon
and you know he'll he can have
we'll give him some food we'll give him
some water most importantly we'll give
him tv cameras he would die if he
couldn't sit in front of tv cameras and
blab all day and i'm saying this is
someone who sits in front of cameras and
blabs for a lot of the day i don't like
it even one one millionth as much as
fauci does well give him all that just
get him out of here get him out of this
country
i would gladly
do it
and it's not just him he's the clearest
example of it he's kind of at the top of
the bureaucrat pyramid
there are a lot of other people working
within our government right now that are
just wielding power and it's very
difficult for us to take it back and
they're willing power in a really unjust
imprudent
way
and
there's no end in sight
what are we supposed to do as we get
into christmas as we get into new year
as we get into 20 22 this thing began at
the end of 2019
what
is what is going to happen well
if fauci has his way we won't go
anywhere with people where we don't know
their vaccination status
you said earlier this week that if
you're vaccinated you should feel
comfortable traveling and
celebrating the holidays with with your
family uh do you still believe that
no i do if you are vaccinated and
boosted and are prudent when you travel
when you're in an airport to be wearing
a mask all the time you have to be
wearing a mask on a plane
do not do things like go to gatherings
where there are people who you do not
know
what their vaccination status is if you
do that and some people are even going
the extra step or the extra mile
of maybe even getting tested when you
have people coming over the house we now
have a much wider availability
of point of care test that you can get a
result in about 15 minutes so you might
want to do that if you do these things
uh john i do believe that you can feel
quite comfortable with a family setting
the dinners and the gatherings that you
have around the holiday season
nothing is 100 percent risk-free but i
think if you do the things that i just
mentioned you'd actually mitigate that
risk enough to feel comfortable about
being able to enjoy the holiday
you can
maybe feel comfortable about seeing your
family
in a
relatively private environment
if you know for certain
which
experimental drugs they've shot into
their veins and you see a test then
maybe you can allow
aunt sally to come over for christmas
dinner so declareth
dr fauci
if you want to listen to something that
is a lot
more calming and interesting than dr
fauci's voice i would recommend you
check out the jordan harbinger show
which is a podcast you you should have
already been listening to recently
jordan had on oliver north and the woke
mob really came after him for this he
said he's been getting attacked just for
doing the interview and i highly
recommend you check it out jordan's show
which apple named one of its best of
2018 is aimed at making you a better
informed more critical thinker so you
can get a sense of how the world
actually works and come to your own
conclusions about what's happening even
inside your own brain each episode is a
conversation with a different
fascinating guest and when i say there's
something for everyone here i really
mean it in one episode jordan talks to a
hostage negotiator from the fbi who
offers techniques on how to get people
to like and trust you which sounds
pretty useful and a little spooky at the
same time lots of science some pretty
crazy stories from spies and mafia
enforcers and art forgers the guy has
got everything we really enjoy this show
we think you will too there's so much
here head on over to jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or search the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b as in boy i-n as in nancy
g-e-r is in really go do it
go check it out on apple podcast spotify
or wherever you listen to podcasts
notice that dr fauci is not just
concerned that people get vaccinated
he is concerned
that we all be able to know with
certainty whether or not someone has
gotten vaccinated
and those are different things
it's not so much about the vaccine
status
as it is about
knowing which is why i have a little bit
of a different take on how to handle all
the fauchioche stuff and the biomedical
security state than some of my fellow
conservatives
some of my fellow conservatives i think
with good intentions and
we just have a tactical disagreement
here
they want to make a big deal about
publicly saying whether or not yes i've
gotten vaccinated i love the vaccines
the vaccines are so great or no
absolutely not i hate this vaccine and
i'm never getting vaccinated ever again
if anyone tells you that i've been
vaccinated it's a complete lie
i don't think it is a good idea
to
make a
make it a matter of public knowledge
if you have gotten the vaccine
how many of the vaccines you've gotten
well you know i i
here is my card here's this card i'm
publishing this here's the chip in my
arm
i think that
not only is it
does the government wield power by
making you get the vaccine or not i
think they get power
by knowing
whether or not you've gotten it right
now there are just these flimsy cards
right these flimsy little cards that you
show there aren't really a ton of
central databases at least that we know
about
you can show people a picture on an
iphone and
you say oh there's my vaccine card and
that's fine you ca if someone asks you
hey have you been vaccinated even if you
have not received the fauchiachi you can
say without lying you can very often say
yes i have been maybe you've gotten the
meningitis vaccine maybe you've gotten
the hepatitis b vaccine maybe who knows
you can say that
and there can be a lot of uncertainty
okay and i think that is a good thing i
think there's more than one way to skin
a cat
all right i think that the reason that
we have laws
protecting medical privacy is because
medical information is very powerful and
i think what the libs are trying to do
here what the liberal establishment the
fouchies are trying to do is get gather
perfect knowledge and then it's really
easy then you can just
you know dangle more sticks and carrots
in front of the people who have gotten
the fouchy algae and you can
anathematize the people who
very publicly refuse to get it but what
about what if they don't know how many
people have it you actually saw this in
the public policy joe biden did not
push for the osha mandate and some of
the federal vaccine mandates until polls
showed that the majority of people had
gotten at least one shot of the vaccine
he couldn't have done it before
it was the knowledge that allowed him to
do it so i just think that we ought to
be wise
as serpents and innocent as doves and
recognize that what is
more valuable to the liberal ruling
class even than forcing everyone to take
this drug or their 15th booster shot
is
knowing exactly who has done what and
exactly how and in exactly what ways
there are plenty of reasons
medical and religious to avoid getting
this
vaccine and i think
playing it a little more coy is is maybe
uh going to be a more successful way to
go as the biomedical security state
goes on
we just got some really bad news about
that from
the court of appeals which we'll get to
in a second first though a little bit of
good news just to
just to ease everybody up a little we're
going into christmas this is supposed to
be a joyful time well here's a little
bit of joy joe manchin
is a no he's a solid no
on joe biden's build-back better plan
this would be joe biden's
single legislative achievement it's
basically the whole agenda
in law and mansion says this is the
one of two moderate democrats he says
sorry buster we ain't doing it i've
always said this brett
if i can't go home and explain it
to the people of west virginia i can't
vote for it
and i cannot vote to continue with this
piece of legislation i just can't
i've tried everything humanly possible i
can't get there
you're done this is this is a no
this is a no
this is a no
it's over
on the one hand this is courageous joe
manchin even though he's a moderate
democrat from a conservative state
and
even though he's obviously doesn't want
to go along with this radical spending
still he's bucking his own party and and
the president who's in his own party so
that's courageous on the other hand it's
common sense
joe biden's approval rating is about 38
his vice president's about 28 27
the rest of the cabinet the high mark is
thirty eight percent that's pete bootage
edge
the they're underwater on every single
issue right now so it's just if you're
just looking at the polls of what people
support
the majority of americans don't support
the biden agenda and certainly the
majority of west virginians do not so
politically
i think joe manchin is probably making
the right decision too
the way this is being reported is that
one senator is holding up the biden
agenda
that's not true
51 senators are holding up the biden
agenda it's 51 okay and then there's 49
senators who were voting for it
kamala harris would break the tie if it
were 50 50 but it's not so it's dead
ilhan omar furious about this
ilhan omar of the squad tweets out quote
let's be clear mansion's excuse is bs
she uses the whole word though
the people of west virginia would
directly benefit from child care
pre-medicare expansion and long-term
care just like minnesotans this is
exactly what we warned would happen if
we separated buildback better from
infrastructure
that's what she's saying
i also love when these politicians say
let's be clear
it's kind of like let's be honest
which is an admission that i wasn't
previously being honest or in admission
i wasn't previously being clear and so
she says look i might be a dishonest
person but i really don't like what
manchin's doing and this is bs and she
uses the word another slight digression
i don't think politicians should go blue
in public i'm not saying they shouldn't
talk like sailors or you know shouldn't
shouldn't at least be tolerated to talk
like sailors in smoke-filled rooms or at
bars but i don't i don't like seeing
that in in public from our actual
statesmen and especially not from lady
politicians
i just don't like it i just i think men
and women are different
it's it's worse when women do it
it's worse to swear in front of women
and it's it's kind of worse to hear
women swearing in public if especially
if they're politicians roseanne barr
gets a pass ellen degeneres but members
of congress i don't think so i don't
think so buddy
which means after that slight digression
the senate is adjourning for the rest of
the year the buildback better thing is
dead for right now
and while republicans are celebrating i
i want to point out to you
what this means for our government
because what this what this means is
joe biden doesn't really have any
legislative achievement in his first
year
and now we're heading into the midterm
so politicians are going to be even more
risk-averse next year and then if he
gets shellacked in the midterms they'll
have to
pivot very likely or
his agenda will just be completely
obstructed by republicans and so that
would be it you might not get any
legislative achievement for the entire
presidency and yet
this has been one of the most radical
years in our government ever
huh that's weird
joe biden hasn't been able to get
basically anything he wants passed into
law
through the congress
even though he has
unified government right democrats have
the senate democrats of the house
democrats at the white house
and yet
he has been very effective at upending
our entire way of life
of wielding power he did a ton he
practically opened the border
he gave de facto amnesty to lots of
illegal aliens he surrendered
afghanistan he made 100 million
americans or more than 100 million
americans take the fouchy algae and he's
he's gaining even more power to do that
through the through the osha
uh
mandate through the right he's he's
mandating that the occupational safety
and health administration mandate that
the employers with 100 or more employees
make but he's so he's wielding power in
these
really weird ways that are outside of
schoolhouse rock it's not i am a bill up
on capitol hill it's not what we
consider to be the constitutional order
but he's wielding a ton of power the man
doesn't even need to pass laws
that's kind of archaic
that's so passe
that's not really how the government
works anymore the government works less
and less like a democracy
or a republic
and it works much more like an oligarchy
that rules regardless of
forget the will of the people regardless
even of the constitutional
order
pretty clear from the sixth circuit
court of appeals you know that the daily
wire is
suing the biden administration right now
we've gotten a lot of good news
especially from the fifth circuit court
of appeals well now the sixth circuit
court of appeals
ruled that they are going to allow
biden's mandate to go into effect biden
ordered the mandate then the courts said
no we're going to put a stay on the
mandate until this is decided by the
higher courts now the sixth circuit says
no we're going to put a stay on the
state we're going to make the mandate go
into effect right now
and then we'll see what the higher
courts decide later
it
is really raising the stakes it's
raising the
stakes almost as much as we see gas
prices raising these days which is why
you got to check out get upside what if
i told you that you could make up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
you fill up
just by downloading the free get upside
app in the app store or google play
right now actually
you know what you could you could call
me a liar if i told you that you could
call me a liar because if you use promo
code knowles k wles you can get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up which means up to 50 cents cash back
do not pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
just download the app for free and use
promo code knowles kwles to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank some people who drive a lot are
making as much as two to three hundred
dollars a month cash back there's no
catch the cash back gets added right to
your account you can cash out any time
to your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands
download the free get upside app use
promo code knowles canon wlis to get up
to 50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank that is code
knowles canada l-e-s
if you're not aware ben shapiro just
released a new series exclusive to the
daily wire it's called the search the
show is a voyeuristic view
of his closest and most influential
friends
talking with him sharing their inklings
and their personal lives over coffee his
great friend jordan peterson is the
first to join him the premiere episode
is available only at dailywire.com so if
you are not a member yet now is the
perfect time to sign up head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe to sign up today
clips of the show will be available on
youtube but i can promise you these are
meaty juicy conversations and you'll be
missing out a lot if you do not
subscribe right now we'll be right back
with a lot more
so here is what the
sixth circuit court of appeals said this
was really late on friday that this news
broke they ruled two to one to let the
vaccine mandate go into effect
according to judge jane branstetter
strange who is some obama chicky on the
court she says quote recognizing that
the old normal is not going to return
employers and employees have sought new
models for a workplace that will protect
the safety and health of employees who
earn their living there
in need of guidance on how to protect
their employees from covet 19
transmission while reopening business
employers turned to osha so
the spookiest part to me is not that
she's going to let this
radical rule go this unconstitutional
rule in my humble opinion go into effect
before the supreme court resolves the
disputes between the lower courts
the craziest part to me is that first
sentence recognizing that the old normal
is not going to return
what we considered to be life as we knew
it
not having to inject yourself with
experimental drugs to to potentially
maybe
i guess possibly defend against a virus
that doesn't pose a grave threat to the
vast majority of people
being able to travel and breathe air and
not have some filthy stupid mask muzzle
ourselves the whole time
being able to rule ourselves through our
government rather than just having dr
fauci who's been there through seven
presidential administrations and
probably will be there seven more just
tell us what to do at his own whims
that's not coming back
that's not coming back and so this is
my suggestion people write in all the
time michael my my office is telling me
i need to
get the vaccine i need to show proof of
vaccination i need to do this i need to
do that
reminds me of the people who say michael
what if a restaurant demands that i have
the vaccine what
my advice to you is there's more than
one way to skin a cat
that's my advice to you
they want to back you in a corner where
they can
force
everyone to comply the people who are
obedient little sheep and comply they'll
get to work with them and then they'll
find out who the dissidents are and
they'll fire them and they'll ostracize
them
and i just think there's more than one
way to skin a cat i don't think that
anyone should do anything immoral or
illegal or unjust i don't think you
should do any of that
but i think that we need to be prudent
and a little bit clever here okay and i
i think that uh if there's a way to get
around the mandate in a way that is not
illegal or immoral or unjust
then then you should do it and i i don't
think that you we should allow the the
libs here in their massive
once-in-a-lifetime power grab to back us
into a corner whereby anything we do we
lose
speaking of public health
new data from the cdc indicates that
fentanyl-related deaths in the united
states have nearly doubled since 2019.
the cdc data was compiled by a group
called families against fentanyl reveals
that
this is now in terms of americans who
are between the ages of 18 and 45
fentanyl is now the number one killer
more deaths than suicide more deaths
than car accidents
more deaths even than
the rhona
now
why is this not a public health crisis
why is dr fauci not on tv every single
day talking about fentanyl i guess
that's not his specialty
in at the nih but why is why is the
fouchy of drug policy not on tv every
day talking about how we need to solve
this this is a
national epidemic this is
killing more
americans 18 to 45 than anything else
because this is an inconvenient crisis
for the ruling class this is a real
crisis and the ruling class is not doing
anything to stop it it's actually
encouraging all the all of the causes of
the fentanyl crisis because
those causes augment their power what is
causing the fentanyl
issue
china is a major source of u.s bound
fentanyl
in 2020 the dea said that china remains
the primary source
of all fentanyl-related substances
trafficked into the united states
now
the other place that they come from
is the open border with mexico just this
past week
authorities seized more than 1.7 million
fentanyl pills coming over the border
through traffickers linked with the
mexico-based sinaloa cartel
but the ruling class benefits from
our relationship with china from massive
trade with china from the major
investment that china has put into the
united states and into american
companies and buying up our national
debt
and so we're not going to get tough on
china and we're not going to shut down
the fentanyl the ruling class benefits
immensely from
mass illegal immigration
over that southern border
the democrats believe that this will
give them a permanent electoral majority
and it probably will as something like
80 percent of
illegal aliens who come over their
children and even their grandchildren
identify with democrats and now with the
new voting laws that the left has been
pushing a lot of those illegal aliens
are are going to be registered to vote
and are already being registered to vote
and the democrats will deny this but
it's right there in their legislation
the fed in the democrat uh federal
election takeover that they they tried
to push earlier this year
they said that illegal aliens will not
be getting registered to vote and also
they'll be getting total amnesty if they
are registered to vote illegally so they
won't be prosecuted for that well why do
you need to put that second provision
and if the first one's true because they
know that illegal aliens are voting we
know that that's happening
and drug out just generally when america
is addicted to a bunch of drugs they're
much easier to control
the regime in power in the united states
does not care about what is right and
what is wrong so much as
us versus them
right that's that's what we're seeing
from the demand to know our vaccination
status
to the punitive mandates that don't seem
to be doing very much in terms of public
health
to
the
policy on other very real crises so less
about right versus wrong which i i doubt
they even really believe in
i doubt they really believe that there's
such a thing as a transcendent moral
order and
truth and evil and
and falsehood and goodness and all these
these real metaphysical categories i bet
they kind of laugh at them in a very
cynical way
it's about us versus them they're going
to take care of their friends they're
going to punish their enemies ayanna
presley proved this just again ayanna
presley the ringo starr of the squad
aoc is paul mccartney she's kind of the
most mainstream ilhan omar's a little
edgier she's john lennon rashida talib
is george harrison
and then anna presica because no one
really cares about her that much she's
ringo ayanna presley just said quote
let's make it plain
this is just like ilha number let's be
clear let's be honest because we're i'm
usually not honest i'm usually not
playing let's make it plain says ayanna
presley student debt is policy violence
we'll keep fighting to relieve families
across the country to make sure our
policies and budgets reflect their lived
experiences and that we build this
grassroots movement to hashtag cancel
student dead together
might be the least plain worded
statement i've ever read it's hard to
make sense of that it doesn't sound like
it was written in english
but the big takeaway is
they're calling everything they don't
like violence
when
people
from the middle class to the upper
middle class
take out student debt
to get useless degrees they're now
demanding that that be subsidized by the
government by some poor people who don't
have these degrees and by wealthier
people and and through the government
they want this to be paid for
and if they have to pay their own bills
that constitutes violence they call
everything they don't like violence to
justify and threaten their own violent
reaction
that's what this is about
when they say your speech is violence
what they're saying is
i will be justified in becoming violent
because i don't like something that you
say when they say your policy is
violence what theirs what they are
saying and threatening is when i become
violent don't blame me you started it
you made me do it
what you make me so mad why did you make
me do it
that's what they're saying
you are not just an opponent to them
you are the enemy
ronald reagan had a line very nice line
very amiable he said
well i don't have enemies
i'm paraphrasing a little the democrats
they're not my enemies only my opponents
the idea being that americans have
enemies abroad but here in domestic
politics while we might have vigorous
debates we still love one another as
americans i don't think the left views
it that way
i think they really think that we're the
enemy and i think that we should be that
i think they think we should be stripped
of our rights we should be forced into
submission and get a bunch of injections
into our blood and be kicked out of our
jobs and be and be
chased out of society and we're evil
white supremacists bigoted terrible
rotten people
who have who have no place and ought to
have their
their businesses burned down and and be
threatened with violence as as the left
threatened us all with violence
throughout most of 2020
which means that we need to take them
much more seriously
when they tell us this stuff now
speaking of drawing lines in the sand
the new president of the heritage
foundation
just got in a ton
of trouble
kevin roberts
who has taken over the heritage
foundation has been around for a long
time
it's a conservative think tank it's gone
through kind of squishier periods and
then more conservative periods the new
president has said
that you
cannot be a movement conservative if you
support same-sex marriage
avik roy
who's on a little bit more of the
squishy side of the conservative
movement
he quoted this
and he said inconveniently that
eliminates 70 of americans from
heritage's conservative movement so much
for reagan's big tent
you know the famous gay marriage
supporter ronald reagan right was he uh
no i think it would have been
unthinkable to him that we would
redefine marriage to take away sexual
difference from the definition of
marriage but now
many people who claim the mantle of
reaganism or buccalism
wrap themselves up in ideas that neither
man ever believed in that would have
been completely outrageous to them they
say no we're the broad-minded we're the
good conservatives we're just going to
redefine every single thing including
sex and human nature itself because
we're and if you disagree you're a bigot
that's kind that's kind of what avigroy
i think is insinuating here look you're
going to lose if you
think that men and women are different
what the new president of the heritage
foundation is saying
is
obviously correct
it doesn't mean you've got to hate gay
guys
you've got to
be judgmental
and
cruel to them and no it doesn't mean
that it means that
if you don't
acknowledge that men and women are
different
and there is such a thing as sex in
human nature and sex has something to do
with marriage
if you don't know that you just can't be
a conservative there's nothing
conservative about you
you
you are
a radical radical leftist by the
standards of about seven years ago
if and so it's that's just a descriptive
fact
and i'm sorry if you don't like that but
that's the the squishes and the libs and
the technic rats are going to freak out
about this because they don't care at
all about culture they don't care at all
about
religion i guess they don't care at all
about the moral underpinnings of society
they don't care at all what they care
about is increasing gdp a little bit and
always expanding the tent so that we
need a big tent
but you can't
ironically you're not going to expand
the tent into a really potent political
movement if you just tear down all the
walls of the tent and then let every
single person in
and every single crazy idea in
you have not expanded the tent you've
abolished the tent at that point
and it's just the case that it cannot be
so
i'm not saying that we need to
persecute homosexuals or anything like
that you
marriage has a meaning if you don't
recognize that the fundamental political
institution has a meaning and that
meaning is closer to what it has always
been understood to mean everywhere in
the world
than what it is now we are pretending it
means as of the last five years then
you're just not a conservative okay
and we want you to be in the
conservative tent we want you to be in
the movement but you've got to correct
that really mistaken idea maybe you've
fallen under the sway of that idea
because the left is really persuasive
and they control the whole culture and
they have kind of brainwashed you for
the past five years i'm sure that's true
but
we're not going to win
the culture and we're not going to win
political battles by surrendering on
every front
if we give up
human nature sex marriage the
fundamental political institution all
the other political institutions by the
way
then it's not going to matter
how
much we cut taxes much as i love a good
tax cut
speaking of women a woman
has been groped
kind of
a woman is making me too allegations not
in hollywood not in washington
not even in
reality but in virtual reality in the
metaverse a beta tester of the virtual
reality simulation world of the
metaverse which is being pushed by
facebook which changed their name to
meta
basically just a video game that you
live in it's just living in the matrix
she has claimed that she was virtually
groped
uh in in this virtual world
she writes quote
sexual harassment is no joke on the
regular internet but being in virtual
reality adds another layer that makes
the event
even more intense
not only was i groped last night but
there were other people there who
supported this behavior which made me
feel isolated in the plaza
which is the
center of the virtual environments
gathering space
a lot of concern i don't i don't i don't
have the article here
but
it's it's making headlines all over the
place and a lot of conservatives are
making fun of it because obviously she
was not she was not groped
she was not roped because to be groped
means to have your body held on to and
this woman's body was probably sitting
in her bedroom
but her mind was in this virtual place
and that's where she was i actually
think she makes kind of a good point
i'm i'm really glad to read this story
and the outrage from the left about this
story
because it means that the the left is
admitting that there's something other
than our bodies
right the left is admitting that we have
a soul
because her body obviously wasn't groped
it was her her soul or her mind or some
other aspect of her person that's not
physical that was groped and i think
that's true because i don't think we're
just our bodies i think you can be
violated in a way that is not corporeal
it's not the same it's not the same as
you know having some guy
pinch you as you walk by
but there is something to that she's
onto something
it actually does matter what you do on
the internet when you go onto the
internet i think a lot of people believe
that you go into fantasy world where the
rules of morality don't matter where uh
social moraines don't really matter you
can just do whatever you want and that
leads to really dark places obviously
you see that a lot with porn you can see
that with video games i guess this is
kind of a combination of the two but
really anything the way we talk to
people
the way the way we behave online does
have something to do with reality
because we're not just physical beings
we're also metaphysical beings
so i think i think it's fair so now what
what does that mean about this this real
world
means that we shouldn't just treat each
other like flesh and meat puppets
means we've got to recognize we do have
souls there is a moral order we've got
to respect that moral order even when
we're in these kind of strange virtual
environments and maybe we should avoid
divorcing our bodies from our souls
entirely maybe living in the metaverse
and plugging the brain stem into the
matrix which is probably what two years
around the corner i don't know i gotta
check in with alex jones he seems to
have a good track record these days
maybe that is uh not a great idea to
divorce those things maybe we need to
recognize we're body and soul we got to
live we got to
behave as though both of those things
matter
not just
the you do you if feels good do it
materialism that the libs push sometimes
not just the gnostic dualism that the
transgenderists push which is that the
body doesn't matter at all and it's just
the metaphysical reality is all that
matters maybe maybe both matter
we got to get back to that speaking of
weird sex stuff before we go
in october
there was a shocking report out
that teachers at a salinas am i
pronouncing that right i don't know
salinas california middle school
secretly recruited students into a
pro-lgbt club
that was disguised as a gender equality
club without their parents knowing this
was not just
teachers you know hosting a club for
kids with you know kind of different
sexual desires or confusion or something
and saying you can show up if you want
this was teachers going in tracking
their students online trying to figure
out which students were maybe interested
in this stuff and then inviting them and
recruiting them it was really creepy
it was grooming i think is what you
would call it well that's what the
parents are calling it so this was this
was presented by abigail schreier
um who wrote the book irreversible
damage about transgenderism for little
girls
these kids were
indoctrinating pupils into accepting
progressive views of sex and gender
coaching students into changing their
gender telling them to hide this
stuff from their parents now the parents
are going out they're calling this
grooming this is a good tactic i think
we need to be a little bit blunter
let's be plain to quote ionopressly
let's be clear to quote ilhan omar
i think we need to be a lot blunter
about these things
these are creepy perverts they should
not
teach our kids
and
they need to be chased out of
polite society kind of like dr fauci
because we can pass laws
and we can we can pass new policy
directives and we can have executive
orders but personnel is policy
right the people that we have
executing on these things are going to
determine what kind of policy we have we
can pass some resolution out of the
senate saying that fauci can or cannot
do something
but who cares there was a ban on gain of
function research dr fauci clearly
didn't care all that much about that
there have been all sorts of there's a
there's a law against perjury dr fauci
doesn't appear to have cared very much
about that personnel is policy and so i
think we got to be a lot blunter we got
to be a lot more willing to own the libs
sometimes and we need to throw these
people out
right now it's looking like we're going
to have a good opportunity to throw the
libs out of office in 2022
some members of congress and who knows
maybe 2024 it depends on whether or not
they they change all the voting rules
again
or we've got the phi beta kappa variant
at that point moving into the 17th year
of the coronavirus and so
all the ordinary rules of government are
going to be suspended again
but yeah maybe look let's say we can get
the president out who's going to replace
him i don't know
if all of these bureaucrats if the
fouchies are still there
if the administrators are still there
even if some of these teachers and some
of these superintendents are still there
then it's not really going to matter
the fact is
joe biden has had basically no
legislative achievements this year and
yet the government has been extremely
effective and extremely radical so it's
going to we're going to have to think
outside the box why is this a serpent
innocent as a dove
in order to change it back i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles shall see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show senator
joe manchin announces he is done with
buildback better and the left is ticked
off that's today on the bench bureau
show give it a listen